science writer Gary tabs has a knack for
subverting conventional wisdom sixteen
years ago he published a groundbreaking
feature in the New York Times Magazine
arguing that decades worth of government
approved nutritional advice attacking
fatty foods and praising carbohydrates
was flat-out wrong ideologically
motivated and was contributing to rising
rates of obesity and diabetes he was
widely attacked including in the pages
of Reason his 2007 book good calories
bad calories followed on that story as
did why we get fat and what to do about
it which came out in 2011 today his
thesis is gaining ground among health
and nutrition researchers and has been
highlighted in places such as the New
York Times and Time magazine i sat down
with tabs in his kitchen in Oakland
California to talk about his latest book
on nutrition the case against sugar
which came out recently in paperback
gary taos thanks for talking to Reason
thanks for having me can you lay out the
opening arguments that you make against
sugar okay we have obesity and diabetes
epidemics everywhere in the world
worldwide they manifest whenever a
population shifts from whatever their
traditional diet is to westernized urban
diet and so you could think of the
Western diet and lifestyle is the vector
that carries obesity and diabetes into
these populations and the question is
what is it in that diet describe the
Western diet does that mean well so
that's a question processed food
sedentary living Totino's pizza rolls my
meter all's Kentucky Fried Chicken and
McDonald's coca-cola
so the whole reason that we live the
things we wait for are the things that
are killing us
it's a simplistic way to think about it
probably wrong though things many of us
live for and it was this is the issue
something in our diet lifestyle causes
obesity and diabetes conventional wisdom
is it's basically caloric overload we
eat too much or were sedentary in the
foods you get too much food available
there there
in a way that makes them irresistible
they have too much salt fat sugar
there's a whole host of theories around
that idea but ultimately it comes down
to we take in more calories and we
expand that causes obesity obesity
increases your risk of type 2 diabetes
both those diseases increase your risk
of heart disease cerebral vascular
disease stroke cancer or Alzheimer's you
name at every major chronic disease and
we see these chronic diseases appearing
in populations when they make this
nutritional shift so the question is
what is and the argument I'm making this
book is that sugar is the prime suspect
always been the prime suspect because
you can track these epidemics back in
time now you say it's always been a
prime suspect but really you know at
least in the past 40 or 50 years we've
been told and this is a lot of your work
what we've been told don't worry about
sugar worry about fat worry about the
meat and that beautiful arc of fat
around the edge that you might bristle
up a little bit that's key to the story
that's how I entered into it as an
investigative journalist is we have this
belief system that began and is a
hypothesis in the 1950s and we started
to be tested in the 1960s and was never
confirmed which is a dietary fat causes
heart disease when it comes to calories
that is the enemy so by the 1980s a
healthy diet was being defined as a
low-fat low-salt diet and this explains
snack well cookies and things like that
what a delicious way to cut the fat
snack wells chocolate sandwich cookies
one of the things that happened in the
80s when we embrace this low-fat healthy
diet synchronicity is the government the
CDC started telling industry to produce
low-fat foods so we could take foods
like the iconic example is yogurt the
high-fat food by definition you remove
some of the fat now you have this kind
of insipid watered-down tasteless thing
and to make it taste good you put back
fruit and sugar high fructose corn syrup
and now you've got a heart-healthy diet
food that you sell these little packets
and we see them everywhere
did the shift from a higher fat or a
more balanced I had actually to a low
fat low fat low salt sugar did it
achieve the goals that were predicted
for it you could look at heart disease
mortality and it's come down and the
nutrition communities have a look people
aren't dying from heart disease as much
therefore our advice is right and then
people like me say yeah but we're not
interested in mortality because we're
also selling billions of dollars in
statins every year and billions of
dollars in blood pressure drugs and
we're doing you know hundreds of
thousands of heart surgeries a year
putting in stents you know doing bypass
as if mortality wasn't coming down we'd
have a real problem
question is what's happening to
incidents are we seeing less heart
disease because we're preventing it with
changes and die and there's no evidence
you know you described an early battle
over many of these questions between
academic nutritionists who
overwhelmingly took the energy balance
approach to nutrition you know did you
lose weight if you burn more calories
than you take in versus what they
characterized as quack doctors so you
have an academic research community
that's dominated post-world War two in
the US by nutritionists who are studying
animals for the most part 1959-60 rosin
yellow and solomon Burson invented
technology that allows hormones to be
measured accurately it's the science of
endocrinology finally has a tools they
need to understand things like hormonal
regulation of fat accumulation and
yellow and Burson say look insulin
drives fat accumulation so maybe this
link between type 2 diabetes it'll be
maybe the type 2 diabetics are obese
because of the insulin and nobody cares
because they know ok except the doctors
so the doctors are like all of us
they're getting fat right what do you do
if you're getting fat well you try what
everyone tells you to do which is eat
less and exercise more and if that
doesn't work which it doesn't then you
look if you're smart you look for other
methods so some of them read the diet
literature and try various diets some of
them actually read the same medical
literature I did so Afghans famously
read the same studies I read 40 years
later there's a conventional thinking
that carbohydrates are fattening bread
pasta potatoes you know every women
described them as going right to their
hips maybe if I get rid of the
carbohydrates and replace it with fat
because that's the one macronutrient
that doesn't stimulate insulin secretion
maybe I'll lose weight so if you try it
and it works so it is a place where kind
of people outside of the official
research community were you know
desperate to get skinny or have their
patients get skinny so they tried a
bunch of different things obesity is one
of these subjects where it helps to have
a weight problem if you don't understand
what it's like to get fatter and fatter
you're in and you're out regardless of
what you do or to be fifty pounds fatter
than your schoolmates in high school
regardless of what you do you just don't
understand obesity were you you're a
trim guy were you a fat load at some
point in their life LP when I was a kid
it was one of the interesting things my
brother was a mathematician was you know
you could see every vein on his body and
I was a chubby you know he was tolerance
thin I mean he couldn't gain weight if
he wanted to and I was just a chubby kid
puberty you know helped yeah and then I
became an athlete and that helped but my
brother and his peak was six foot five
weighed about 195 was a rower number
Freud said Anatomy is destiny so he
wrote crew and I was 6 foot 2 and could
get up to 240 and I played football we
both ate as much as we could that's what
we did we were kids you know and I often
wonder it's like why would you possibly
think that I was thicker than him
because I ate more exercise less I was
just thinking than him that was my body
in the book you documental long history
of public nutrition advice being
intertwined with politics in this case
so let's talk about the sugar lobby how
did king sugar you know get its crown in
in the American economy and kind of been
American diet well sugar used to be very
expensive it's hard to grow it's only
grows in specific in tropical regions
you if you can't just transport the
sugarcane around the world in them we're
finding the sugar out of it afterwards
if we got to get the sugar out quickly
I'm refining it's a horrible job it was
done by slice it was done by slaves the
sugar industry is at the heart of the
slave trade the industrial revolution
comes along getting in the late 18th
century and suddenly sugar gets cheaper
and cheaper to refine and 1840s the
candy industry the chocolate industry
and the ice cream industry I'll start
off the soft drink industry in
particular just explodes by 1900 we're
consuming about 90 pounds per capita
which is almost a 20-fold increase in
that century every industry it's like an
arms race nutritionists say no no no and
the marketers say if we don't do it also
we're out of business and they fall one
after another and by the 1960s you've
got cereals that are 40 50 percent sugar
and and that are advertising assets
right this is like Sugar Smacks honey
and sugar make it different and
wonderful a circus of fun to eat you've
got all of the like the smartest minds
in Madison Avenue a PR industry creating
not just cartoon characters to sell but
entire Saturday morning cartoons and
once we grew up on like Rocky and
Bullwinkle I loved Rocky and Bullwinkle
is for juices come in in the 1930s okay
Sunkist coalition of California orange
growers don't know they have to do
something with their oranges
you can't sell enough and you can't move
enough so you turn them into juice you
sell them as juice and you advertise
them as healthy because of the vitamin C
we're coming off this age of the new
nutrition which was all about vitamins
and vitamin deficiency diseases you go
back to what we evolved to eat and the
sugar and those apples and kids are now
getting that within 20 minutes awakened
up in the morning and they're not going
more than an hour and a half two hours
over the course of the day without yo
and the course of a day they're
consuming almost a year's worth of what
they evolved to eat
and you're you know at various points
the USDA or other government agencies
that kind of gave dietary
recommendations wouldn't even think to
say oh well you know glasses of apple
juice or orange juice or sugar to this
day when you're told to eat a lot of
fruits and vegetables it's because
they're vitamin rich in one the
conventional thinking orange juice is
healthy because it's full of vitamins
and in the alternative thinking the
world I live in now it's unhealthy
because it's basically sugar water you
could take coca-cola and the vitamin C
you know tablet and you got the same
thing talk about why the government
would kind of push that or would have
that blind spot and the role of the
sugar industry okay what the sugar
industry they're always a very powerful
Lobby because sugar was a very uh I mean
it was a vital product the import the
food industry was dependent on it so the
sugar Lobby was always considered
incredibly powerful beginning in the
1920s the industry creates his sugar
Association basically to help advertise
sugar consumption post-world War two
when the artificial sweetener industry
begins to come of age and people started
thinking and hey you know I'm getting
fatter I could drink these sugar free
calorie free drinks as well and the
industry starts producing in the
newspapers now have something to measure
which is the amount of diet sodas being
produced so they can write about the
diet craze and the sugar industry has a
problem because people are saying sugars
fattening so this sugar Association
start saying calories a calorie that's
the general it's the bedrock belief of
the nutrition obesity community so they
start advertising widely and starting PR
campaigns to combat this argument that
sugar is fattening and they do it by
basically just taking what the
nutritionists are giving them the
nutritionists are giving them bad
science the obesity researchers are
giving them bad science and all serves
to exonerate sugar here's the sugar
lobby actually paying for studies or
they they are paying for research they
began paying for
Church in World War two but then again
that was common practice a sugar
industry kind of pioneered and I don't
think they did it for public relations
reasons they wanted to find other uses
for sugar so they funded some of the
best sugar biochemists in the world and
they wrote about it in science magazine
would annually we're on articles about
the sugar industry you know who they
were funding and why they were funding
it because of a good thing it helped
cement some allies later because if
somebody's been paying your bills for
twenty years you tend to be fond of them
and that's where the conflict of
interests come in and then in the 1960s
with this idea that dietary fat was a
problem dietary fat caused heart disease
some of the people pushing that having
to be longtime recipients of sugar
industry large ass now they could pay
those people to write articles saying
dietary fat is a problem not sugar and
this was conventional thinking the only
people who were claiming sugar were the
problem with these sort of Fringe
British nutritionists who were perceived
as quacks so what about the attack on
artificial sweeteners so saccharin or
certainly cyclamates was banned in the
late sixties or seventies yeah saccharin
was almost banned or it was for a bit
but it carries a warning on it yeah
where did that where did the interest in
saying these were carcinogenic or these
well that came from the sugar industry
so the saccharine and cyclamates were
direct competitors um interestingly the
beverage in hears about the beverage
industry and the sugar industry split as
a beverage industry was happy to sell
artificially sweetened on artificial
sweeteners are cheaper but the sugar
industry thought his direct threat to
their body billon and it was and there's
a quote in the New York Times that I
quote my book a sugar industry executive
hopping to spending a half million
dollars on research trying to find
anything that an artificial sweetener
does it's damaging they would give
female rats the equivalent of 60 cans a
day of soda and hope that they would
produce rats with birth defects so they
could say you know it's as bad as the
little mine I mean they were looking for
anything
and this executive in the New York Times
is quoted as saying if someone could
undersell you one cent to a dime
wouldn't you throw a brick bat at them
if you could if our government and and
other public health institutions
universities whatnot if they're
consistently offering bad nutritional
advice and bad dietary guidelines what
do you do about that would it what is
what's the response the problem because
they're a solution here or do we just
kind of say screw it and you know in the
science as I was in which I was raised
so physics and the people who taught me
science when I wrote my first two books
in physics and chemistry and hard
sciences it's a it's the last thing you
want to do is get an assumption in
accepted into the theory of how things
work without rigorously testing and
because then people will build on it
from there and it'll grow and infect the
whole sort of thought construction and
you'll end up with them gonna beat this
metaphor to death sort of a house of
cards and there'll be no way to go back
on and then those are Sciences that have
no influence on everyday life so in a
field like nutrition and obesity
research you've now got these enormous
institutional dogmas built in that that
you know I and others are arguing or
simply wrong who do you trust and how do
you get the institutions to change their
belief system so right now and you know
co-authoring an order the British
Medical Journal was running a series of
nutrition policy and their way of
dealing with it is by assigning writers
from these different belief system song
I'm a co-author on an article on dietary
fat along with the former head of the
Harvard nutrition department who thinks
I'm the worst journalist he's ever met
and who does a form of science that I
consider a pseudoscience but that is
kind of the Enlightenment model of
science right that you you have
competing truth claims and then you kind
of put them in you know a cockfighting
ring well saying what's the cockfighting
ring that's
you know the cockfighting ring is
experimental tests is hypothesis and
test you have a hypothesis you do an
experiment you intervene limiting the
number of variables you change the
problem with these Sciences which is it
says you can't really test these
hypotheses they're too hard to do I mean
you could if you had enough societal
motor base if you're willing to spend 10
billion dollars the way we do to try and
find out if the Higgs boson exists and
the high-energy physics and build you
know you get everyone to work together
you identify the key questions and you
spend whatever money is necessary do you
think food producers you know obviously
they have you know institutional
legacies that they want to protect but
they also I mean private industry spends
billions of dollars a year on research
are they capable of doing disinterested
research
well the assumption is no yeah so you
know nowadays there's a whole
journalistic industry of identifying
conflicts of interest when researchers
do take money from industry there are
models which work better where you just
have the industry you know donates
basically money for research to
clearinghouses or the government which
then identifies what things have to be
studied but um you know if I'm right the
arguments I'm making is you have an
entire multiple generations of nutrition
and obesity research to really
fundamentally don't know how to do
science they don't know how to think
critically how to keep multiple
hypotheses in their head at one time how
do what it means to rigorously test
hypotheses so if you even if you had
them do the studies they would probably
do a bad job at various point you
compare sugar sugar to a drug you know
to kind of go into a different register
of government malfeasance the you know
the government has arbitrarily declared
certain drugs good and certain drugs
that licit the war on drugs has been a
failure the war on tobacco I guess has
been successful in terms of helping to
drive down the amount of people who
smoke are you proposing anything along
the lines of a war on sugar no no a
government interference were
is me the same way I think it worries
you guys is you know the whole this
whole story is about government
interference and when arrived if they
had stayed out of things in the 60s
through the 80s and never inflicted us
with this what I think are incorrect
ideas and a healthy diet is inherently
it's sort of low in fat low in salt we
might the scientists might have had the
time to get the science right and we
might have really understood what's
happening there is that structuring
think we're obviously you know I guess
this actually came up in the Obamacare
debates about whether or not the
government could mandate you buy
broccoli etc it's never as direct as
that but when the FDA or I guess more
likely the USDA the Department of
Agriculture sets up federal guidelines
those influenced how people talk about
things how grants get given what gets
served at school lunches which then it
changes tastes etc yeah so there's a
real indirect power by which the
government really does get to set a lot
of dietary practice yeah and I have what
is maybe too simplistic a notion you
know we have these obesity and diabetes
epidemics it's unambiguous we identify
the cause now we know what we shouldn't
be eating and if we get that message
across I don't know how much government
regulation how people cut back on
smoking and how much the awareness that
smoking causes lung cancer did I didn't
quit because of government regulations I
quicks I don't want to kill myself and
that was coughing all the time and it
was clear that was cigarette related so
if we could get people to understand if
assuming I'm right sugar is the problem
and you get rid of sugar and refined
high glycemic index carbs if you don't
want to be obese and diabetic I think
yeah those are awful disorder diabetes
prevalence in this country is increased
700 percent since the early 1960s we
have to get that straight as long as we
think it's eating too much and
exercising too little and sedentary
behavior and the obesity diabetes
community oh say these are
multifactorial complex diseases which
means the NIH funds thousands of
researchers to look at hundreds of
things and we're going to say it's all a
little bit of this a little bit of that
some things triggering the epidemics
everywhere and it's probably the same
thing everywhere and that no hypothesis
should be it something simple and sugars
not just at the scene of the crime when
it happens in populations at the scene
of the crime in the human body which is
the liver there is a cause and if we
understand that then we then I think
there'll be a societal move to fix it
but again we have to get it right we
have to get the science right well we
will leave it there we have been talking
with Gary tabs he's a science writer
whose most recent book is the case
against sugar out in paperback Gary
thanks for talking to reason Thank You
Nick
for reason I'm Nikolas
[Music]